here's an interesting story for economic
context it's really important when we
talk about how much things cost in
government in politics in society it's
important to consider what other things
cost in government as well so for
example like when we hear a proposal for
Medicare for all and we hear a dollar
figure for what it would cost those
dollar figures are so huge that they can
be meaningless to us and it's sort of
like thinking about a time duration of a
million years how do we as humans
conceive of the time duration a million
years it's really difficult when you
consider the lifespan of the average
humans so when we compare Medicare from
when we look at Medicare for all we
should also consider well what do we
already spend on health care what do we
spend on the military we need context in
order to really understand the economic
price tag that exists for programs so
when we talk about the cost of Obama
care or the cost of trumps tariffs it's
useful to have analogies and other data
and there happens to be research from
National Taxpayers Union Foundation
which points out that this latest round
of Donald Trump's tariffs have made it
so that the total increase in cost to
Americans for Trump's tariffs are
greater than the average per person
taxes for Obama care okay
the cost of the enacted tariffs before
the additional tariffs that will start
on January 1st of 2019 will be about 42
billion dollars the cost of the
Affordable Care Act it's going to be 34
billion dollars next year the tariffs
will cost Americans more than Obama care
which we were told is too expensive and
we can't afford afford this is what many
people including Trump don't understand
about tariffs Trump talks about putting
tariffs on other countries the tariffs
are paid for by the business is
importing for those countries so when
you say we are going to put a tariff on
China for goods that they export to the
United States
it's the businesses buying those goods
here that actually pay for that that
means layoffs that means moving
manufacturing out of the u.s. that means
finding ways to circumvent the law to
avoid the tariffs and since we're
talking about tariffs this is also a
good time to talk about the
trade deficit yesterday and earlier
today we talked about the budget deficit
Donald Trump successfully framed himself
to his supporters as an expert on trade
who knew how to fix it and in doing so
Trump talked about how the trade deficit
was too high and trade deficit means
when you import more than you export you
have a trade deficit when you export
more than you import you have a trade
surplus Donald Trump has been messing
with these tariffs for several months
now and lo and behold the trade deficit
has increased during this time to a
six-month high soybean shipments keep
declining imports keep climbing meaning
not only are Trump's tariffs not working
to reduce the trade deficit but American
companies are spending more money on
foreign goods rather than redirecting
that money domestically if you are an
economic nationalist and most people are
like economic nationalism is mostly
unquestioned among the left and right
although there are people in our
audience who I know disagree economic
nationalism means that you believe the
economic policy of the US for example
should be geared towards helping the
u.s. and Americans and American
companies that's what Donald Trump
claims to be doing economic nationalism
the policy is failing by the standard of
economic nationalism and we know Trump
comes from the business world he's
running America like a business the
problem is that many of trumps
businesses went bankrupt and the
employees lost their jobs if you're a
supporter of the tariffs and I know that
there are people in the audience who are
please get in touch and tell me when
will the tariffs start having a positive
impact because so far the tariffs are
costing Americans money and the trade
deficit which was according to Donald
Trump himself one of the main statistics
pieces of data that justified this trade
war has been going in the opposite
direction compared to what Donald Trump
claimed would have what happened so I
want to hear from you if you support the
tariffs
when will they measurably start doing
something good for Americans and for
American businesses get in touch with me
including via our voicemail number two
one nine to david p today's episode is
sponsored in part
by the music streaming app title which
is there to foster the relationship
between artists fans and importantly
values diversity in music and also
supports criminal justice reform titles
4th annual benefit concert called Title
X Brooklyn is all about supporting
criminal justice reform reforming and
changing the circumstances that have led
to more than two-thirds of prisoners
serving life without parole for
nonviolent offenses being
african-american and all net proceeds
from Title X Brooklyn will help to
support charities like reform like the
Innocence Project like cut 50 and the
equal justice initiative that are
working specifically on issues of
criminal justice the concert is going to
have some great performances including
Lil Wayne Meek Mill Anderson PAC and
Lauryn Hill Lauryn Hill okay there will
be a free live stream of the entire show
on October 23rd find out more donate to
the cause and tune in at title dot-com /
Brooklyn that's TI d al comm forward
slash Brooklyn